dans un film américain ge pas si vous
l'avez vu jerry maguire tom cruise avait
une réplique célèbre hilaire a répété
pendant deux minutes chaumine money
chomis de manille ça veut dire en
français montre moi l'argent dis moi
combien tu mets et bien on le sait
depuis ce matin olivier véran veut
mettre 6 milliards d'euros sur la table
pour augmenter les salaires à l'hôpital
et dans les ehpad
ça concerne les personnels hospitaliers
hors médecins ce chiffre est-il une
bonne base de négociation
écoutez moi je me méfie toujours des
annonces des milliards annoncés ce que
l'on sait sur sur l'hôpital il ya
nécessité de revoir complètement la
grille des salaires mais les
déroulements de carrière pour le
personnel hospitalier mais il n'ya pas
que ça il ya le sujet du personnel la
répartition entre le personnel
administratif et le personnel soignant
on a on est dans un système hospitalier
en france on a une part beaucoup plus
importante que dans tous les autres
systèmes hospitaliers du personnel
administratif par rapport au choix niant
et ensuite les plateaux de soins la
complémentarité entre le public et le
privé la gouvernance c'est tous ces
sujets qui tous ces soins sont sur la
table le cirill sont négociées sur que
les syndicats disaient ça fait trois
semaines qu'on négocie on n'a toujours
pas d'argent là on a un chiffre une
enveloppe est ce que ça vous semble
cohérent coûté ça c'est aux partenaires
sociaux de le dire voyons comment
commencer milliards vont être utilisés
comment ils vont être débloqués sur quel
calendrier je crois que il ya une
annonce de 2,6 milliards mais il n'y a
pas de calendrier encore à ma
connaissance donc prenons le temps de
regarder de regarder tout cela avant d'
avant d'avoir un avis de l'est les
syndicats demandent 300 euros
d'augmentation pour les infirmières
notamment et les aides soignants ça vous
semble trop où ça vous semble normal non
il ya un retard à discutable le mans est
objectivement ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui il ya un retard et à
décalage de rémunération compte tenu des
exigences le personnel soignant a
notamment choisi infirmiers mais c'est
vrai aussi pour les médecins vous savez
les lélés les praticiens hospitaliers il
ya aussi un retard
il ya un décalage aujourd'hui entre un
médecin hospitalier et un médecin dans
le privé qui est difficilement
explicable alors ça c'est sous ces
sujets là ce chiffre des 6 milliards
le devraient être partagés avec le
secteur privé affirme olivier ferrand ce
n'était pas forcément prévu ça ça a
surpris des gens à ce que ça est ce que
pour vous c'est 6 milliards doivent
aller uniquement à l'hôpital public et
aux ehpad publics où ça peut être
partagé avec le privé sur les
équipements moi je raisonne j'ai j'ai
été maire j'étais président dans mon
hôpital
il faut raisonner en plateau de soins et
vouloir
on a bien vu d'ailleurs dans cette crise
là où on a réussi à trouver rapidement
la complémentarité public privé les
régions ont répondu beaucoup mieux donc
il ya aussi la nécessité d'accompagner
les hôpitaux privés de raisonner en
nombre de lits est encore une fois en
offre de soins autre annonce dominique
sans parler d'elles concerne les
nouvelles règles du chômage partiel
l'état va donc continuer à soutenir des
entreprises à partir du 1er juillet
pendant deux ans les salaires et
toucheront 84 % de leur salaire jusqu'au
1er octobre puis 72% le gouvernement a
t-il raison de soutenir massivement de
continuer à soutenir massivement pendant
deux ans ses entreprises et ses salariés
même si comme dit dominique seux ça
coûte cher
c'était un bon outil le chômage partiel
est un bon outil simplement c'est un bon
outil mais il faut en sortir il faut que
la france se remettent au travail on a
besoin aujourd'hui d'accompagner les
entreprises en sortir ça veut dire qu'on
est contre ce non non non pas du tout
pas du tout j'ai toujours dit que
c'était une bonne mesure pendant deux
ans et les jeux le maintien simplement
il faut regarder il ya des secteurs qui
peuvent redémarrer immédiatement et là
il faut d'ailleurs accompagné en
trésorerie immédiatement les entreprises
l'élément déterminant de la pérennité
d'une entreprise c'est son fonds de
roulement
or là les fonds de roulement se sont
asséchés si on veut que les entreprises
redémarrent il faut remettre de l'argent
immédiatement
c'est pour ça que nous nous avions parlé
d' année blanche sur les sur les charges
fiscales et sociales de façon à ce que
très vite voyez une entreprise qu'à
l'arrêt pendant trois mois et là des
charges fixes à payer donc si
immédiatement ne compense pas ça et ne
redémarre jamais elle est toujours tenu
entre deux christian jacob emmanuel
macron reçoit aujourd'hui à déjeuner les
patrons de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale il devrait confirmer qu'il
veut reporté après la présidentielle les
élections régionales théoriquement
prévues en mars prochain
argument est le suivant la priorité dans
l'année à venir c'est de sauver
l'économie c'est d'appliquer le plan de
relance est pas de faire une campagne
électorale
cet argument n'est t'il pas recevable
c'est dommage que le président de la
république n'ait pas pensé depuis trois
ans qu'elle quelles réformes ont été
faites depuis trois ans on est dans la
continuité n'est pas une fronde il ya
trois ans non mais enfin pendant trois
ans il ya aucune réforme économique ont
été menées
si vous prenez quelques indicateurs
économiques aujourd'hui la france c'est
le pire déficit public d'europe de la
zone euro pardon si le pire déficit
commercial d'europe
c'est le 25e taux de croissance c'est le
taux le plus élevé des prélèvements
obligatoires
on a passé la barre des 48 % c'est un
taux d'endettement jamais atteint avant
que vides 100% du pib
des résultats économiques
catastrophiques rien n'a été fait avant
et alors maintenant le président de la
république va nous dire ben écoutez je
manque un peu de temps donc on est
obligé de décaler des élections mais
c'est le fait du prince
tant qu'on y est quoi c'est un chantage
un déni démocratique c'est quoi vous
êtes contre absolument le report de ces
essais un mélange des deux c'est un
mélange des deux et pourquoi il va pas
nous annoncer qu'on va décaler élection
présidentielle tant qu'il y est ça
pourrait nous dire comprenez mon
quinquennat désolé mais avec le co vide
j'ai pas pu conduire les choses comme je
joue comme je voulais donc on pourrait
aussi décalé il ya un rendez vous
démocratique mais il n'a pas donné la
raison il va mettre sur le plan de
relance mais patron de région qu'ils
vont faire campagne au lieu de 90
argument c'est bien celui là
invraisemblable c'est le fait du prince
voilà le prince décide et donc tout le
monde doit sein de doit s'aligner fin au
nom de quoi les élections régionales
empêchent de mener une réforme de
quelque nature que ce soit au nom de
quoi
ce qui n'a pas été capable de faire en
trois ans comment il va nous expliquer
que pour le faire en 18 mois il a besoin
de décaler les élections et noir sinon
on est dans l'opportunisme politique
on est dans le fait du prince je m'y
opposerai après si président de la
république veut passer en force
il a une majorité enfin il a une
majorité on verra d'ailleurs parce qu'à
part en miettes un peu tous les jours
mais bref en théorie on pourrait
considérer qu'il a potentiellement une
majorité qui le fasse passer en force
mais moi je m'y opposerai mais ce qui
peut faire part des craintes et s'il
peut fait ce qu'il peut faire aussi
emmanuel macron c'est outrepasser les
régions sur le plan de relance et faire
son transfert de compétences et son plan
de relance avec les départs
comment par exemple ce serait pas
cohérent là vous faites votre campagne
électorale et moi je traite avec l'un
des partis ça veut dire vous faites
votre campagne électorale et moi je
m'occupe du reste mais tout ça n'a aucun
sens
ça veut dire aussi qu'on va bloquer les
l'investissement public
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
décalez une élection on l'a vu avec les
municipales
c'est de l'investissement public qui ne
sera pas réalisée qui est décalé dans le
temps et donc c'est des entreprises je
pense notamment au secteur du btp
je pense à tous ces secteurs qui sont
liées à la dépendance à la dépense
publique les régions c'est les lycées
certaines de ses interventions
économiques et donc vous allez voir un
décalage dans le temps et on va reporter
et paralysé la vie des entreprises
vous aviez dit on à trois jours des
municipales vous avez répété à maintes
reprise christian jacob avant le premier
tour hors de question de passer des
accords avec en marche ce serait d
accord de boutiquier finalement surprise
pour le second tour à bordeaux toulouse
strasbourg lyon j'en passe vous avez
accepté d accord avec vous avez accepté
d accord avec en marche pour faire face
aux alliances des écologistes et de la
gauche vous avez fait qu'en marche
contrairement à ce que vous disiez
christian jacob on voulait qualifié
commander accord de boutiquier ou des
accords de second tour différent des
accords de boucane d'abord aucun accord
politique n'était passé avec en marche
il ya localement dans six villes en
france et sur ces civils en france 3 se
sont fait retirer l'investiture dans
marche donc il ya trois sur les les 273
villes de plus de 30 mille habitants il
y a trois villes où il y a eu localement
un accord avec orange voilà alors la
justice la justice reprend ses
investigations dans la fête dit dans la
sphère dit colère du nom du secrétaire
général de l'elysée après les
révélations de médiapart qui a publié
hier une lettre signée des manuels
macron qui dédouanent son bras droit des
accusations conflit d'intérêts qui
pèsent sur lui pour être clair alexis
colère et est soupçonné de conflit
d'intérêts à cause des liens
professionnels et familiaux avec un
armateur msc emmanuel macron assure dans
cette lettre
calexico l'air quand il était son
directeur de cabinet à bercy n'est
jamais intervenu dans les dossiers
concernant msc richard ferrand le
président de l'assemblée nationale a dit
hier cette lettre est une sorte
d'attestation d'employeur comme il s'en
fait tous les jours
en clair c'est une tempête dans un verre
d'eau il n'y a pas de problème colère
vous êtes convaincu ah non d'abord ce
dossier a été classé très opportunément
sans suite nous nous l'avions dénoncé en
hélas le parquet le parquet financier
d'ailleurs dans une inde en une dans un
moment d'intérim du procureur du parquet
national financier le classent très
opportunément sans suite aujourd'hui moi
je vois qu'il est déclassé il est
déclassé avec des suspicions
effectivement de 2,2 de conflit
d'intérêts si je reprends les attendus
prise illégale d'intérêt trafic
d'influencé et défauts de déclaration à
la haute autorité est quoi le problème
c'est l'indépendance du parquet national
financement
c'est à dire que si la sphère été
classée sans suite par un parquet qui ne
soit pas qu'ils soient indépendants
c'est ce rêve il y aura pas de problème
d'abord c'est pendant une période
d'intérim ensuite ce parc national
financiers aujourd'hui on peut nous nous
étions posé la question au monde sa
création on est dans ie dans un
il a été créé sous françois hollande
souffrance pour lutter contre la
délinquance financière
oui enfin en réalité c'était c'est un
bras armé politique
on voit bien d'ailleurs la dépendance on
le voit dans l'autre affaire dans une
affaire fillon on est dans la même chose
d'ailleurs supprimé le concurrent nous
l'avions dit nous étions contre sa
création la démonstration est faite
aujourd'hui quand la procureure nous dit
qu'elle subit des pressions des
pressions du peu du parquet du parquet
général sayyed l'ancien garde des sceaux
je rappelle juste que le garde des
sceaux à l'époque a été condamné il a
été condamné
c'est un nouveau merci la plus longue
les faire plus longue allez merci belle
journée